donc déjà pour toutes les personnes qui
disent que ce n'est pas un métier s'en
est bien un d'ailleurs nous avons fait
notre premier tournage professionnel qui
a été qui était diffusé aujourd'hui sur
un des plus grand site pornographiques
et bien de nous donc le premier tournage
notre premier tournage x voilà de X
pornographiques c'est ça pour un site
pornographique donc c'est plus seulement
sur les réseaux vous êtes aussi non
alors après de toute façon on sait
jamais sur les réseaux les plateformes
privées sont très cadrées attention ça
n'a rien à voir avec les réseaux sociaux
de c'est quoi ça alors on va on va pas
les citer c'est de prénom voilà et c'est
un grand site c'est un grand site
français
parce qu'on travaille pour une de leur
plateforme privée qui est donc en gros
voilà une des une des sociétés
adjacentes de la maison mère qui est
donc le gros site français qui qui
génère le plus de quoi
ils nous ont demandé tout simplement si
on accepte de tourner avec eux voilà
notre film oui exactement il y a un
scénario
non pas spécialement en fait non
justement c'est ça qui est en fait c'est
ça qui est toujours dans la même dans la
même on va dire
voilà parce que non il y a pas de
scénario du tout on est toujours un peu
dans dans
le libre arbitre on fait ce qu'on veut
en fait et non il y a pas de scénario là
c'est quoi c'est une vidéo voilà donc ce
site vous a proposé de faire une vidéo
pour une vidéo qui voilà de vos ébats
où il y a d'autres gens qui passent ça
fait partie de nos limites et de nos
deux personnes ne passent une technique
[Rires]
les personnes qui étaient parce que au
départ il y a eu des interviews etc ce
qu'il y avait d'autres personnes
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des personnes avec
un autrement donc il y a une interview
donc une interview comme voilà une
interview tout à fait ça
exactement et tout le monde est parti à
partir du moment où vous devez se
retrouver tout simplement tous les deux
parce que ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne veut absolument pas donc aujourd'hui
c'est votre métier vous venez dire au
téléspectateurs qu'aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr que c'est notre métier c'est
maintenant vous êtes quand vous demande
ce que vous faites dans la vie vous
dites acteurs de films X
acteurs le nom le nom le nom comme ça
mais en tout cas oui c'est notre métier
c'est un métier qui est en tous les cas
répertorié dans le code du travail qui
voilà qui est soumis au régime de
l'urssafables là-dedans quoi mais oui
parce que ça nous est pas venu on est
heureux comme ça en fait personne
aujourd'hui non bah non il est sorti
aujourd'hui donc on a pas tourné
aujourd'hui on l'a tourné le jour du
dernier plateau justement
c'est chez vous ça se passe non c'est
pas chez nous c'est dans un décor oui
bien sûr et donc vous avez été tourné
vous avez été bien payé ou pas pour le
film on était payé et prévient ou pas ça
ça nous regarde de nous
c'est en fonction du nombre de vues
derrière vous là on peut pas le savoir
personne vous êtes payé ou bien vous
êtes il y a un avaloir par exemple non
il y a pas d'avaloir c'est pas comme
quand on écrit un livre pas du tout non
non on a eu on a eu un cachet qu'on a
voilà tout simplement et combien on ne
dira pas mais évidemment on a été
rémunéré parce que c'est un travail
comme les autres
tous les deux
donc Amandine érection voilà vous disent
que maintenant ils sont professionnels
moi je suis ni étonné ni choqué je l'ai
dit depuis le début maintenant c'est
leur métier c'est leur libre arbitre je
sais qu'ils sont heureux comme ça et
j'ai trouvé effectivement qu'ici il y
avait une sorte d'acharnement contre eux
alors peut-être que je suis minoritaire
mais moi je vous soutiens et vous avez
raison si ça vous épanouit et personne
n'est forcé de regarder c'est à dire que
on ne vous a rien imposé sur ce tournage
personne n'est forcé de regarder si ça
ne vous plaît pas vous regardez pas moi
je enfin que je vous soutiens dans cette
aventure je regarderai pas mais je vous
comprends tout à fait parce que je sais
que vous êtes heureux là dedans donc le
principal c'est d'être heureux bravo à
vous voilà merci c'est pour ça qu'on
changera jamais notre fusil d'épaule en
fait parce qu'on a eu l'impression qu'on
était ensemble
on était sur un procès là franchement ce
serait creuse assise pendant trois jours
d'affilée enfin c'est incroyable
pourquoi vous voulez revenir aujourd'hui
à Amandine ce que c'est VOUS AUSSI
qu'est-ce que vous avez parce que là je
vous sens beaucoup plus calme beaucoup
plus posées
déjà le lundi a déjà été très compliqué
parce qu'on était pas là pour se
défendre donc effectivement déjà je suis
arrivé en plus je suis très sanguine
donc je suis arrivé mardi déjà remonter
à bloc le mercredi voilà le mercredi on
nous a dit voilà qu'une psy ne pseudo
enfin la pseudopie du coup elle est
géniale c'est ton avis c'est pas le mien
devait nous défendre nous a absolument
pas défoncer elle a voulu vous défendre
en fait
elle a retrouvé sa veste à l'instant T
et là clairement là moi à ce moment là
clairement oui j'ai pété un plomb et
donc je n'ai plus laissé la place à la
parole de personne parce que j'ai trouvé
que c'était clairement une appropriée de
sa part par rapport à ce que m'avait
annoncer et même par rapport à ce
qu'elle m'a dit elle avant de rentrer en
plateau moi je l'ai pas du tout trouvé
possible comme beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs j'adore j'adore
elle voulait elle voulait vraiment vous
aider alors là donc vous vous dites pas
que vous dépassez les limites maintenant
en faisant des vidéos sur un au
contraire non vous passez un autre chose
c'est une étape supérieure en fait parce
qu'en fait on fait toujours très
attention à qui on confie justement ce
type de contenu d'accord là il faut
savoir qu'en 2023 il va y avoir une une
loi donc qui va être adoptée de la part
du gouvernement justement pour interdire
l'accès aux mineurs au site
pornographique qui laisse encore les
mineurs accéder à au film et au contenu
qui sont présents sur ces sites-là à
votre plus grand ce projet de faire de
toute façon voilà elle est où il a 17
ans Léo en fait on lui cache rien Léo
c'est le premier outré en fait de
l'indignation des gens et en fait c'est
le premier à trouver ça affligeant de la
façon dont on a été traité ici pendant
trois heures d'affilée vous allez faire
d'autres films on sait pas si on a des
propositions de temps que rentre dans
l'instant ça rend pas de mauvais jeu de
mots on a vu les extraits
dans nos voilà dans nos principaux en
fait à partir du moment où il y a
personne d'autre et que c'est mon mari
et moi oui d'accord ça c'est vraiment
c'est la règle c'est la règle d'or
Alexandre est-ce que vous êtes content
de ce premier film oui bah de façon ça
s'est bien passé oui j'espérais combien
d'entrées
on verra non vraiment vous êtes contents
vous avez accepté tout de suite vous
aussi oui de façon simple ça change pas
non plus
on est marié femme en fait alors
Géraldine question penses de ce nouveau
produit
parce que je vous trouve plus en forme
que la dernière fois très en colère un
bout de trois fois plus apaisée plus
sobre et tant mieux si vous allez mieux
je vais tout bien j'étais en colère quoi
penser moi je sais pas parce que
avant il avait une tombe amateur
professionnel
je voulais vous dire que si on vous
critique et si on critique votre projet
de vie c'est pas qu'on vous aime ou
qu'on vous aime pas moi je suis pas là
pour aimer les gens ou pas les aimer
quand je suis ici je suis là pour donner
mon avis mon opinion et après on est
d'accord où on est pas d'accord donc
Gilles adore et grimpeur rideau moi au
contraire je suis souple
voilà donc ça c'est oui moi je continue
à être choqué pas du tout par rapport au
fait que vous jouiez dans des films
porno je j'ai toujours considéré et je
l'ai dit si en première lors de la
première émission que c'était un vrai
métier c'est pas ça c'est juste moi ce
qui me choque c'est que vous avez accédé
à la notoriété grâce à vos enfants sur
la pas prémédité encore une fois oui non
mais oui mais je sais mais on avait déjà
nos délires bloqués dans ce destin là
pour moi parce que à partir du moment où
vous avez accédé à votre notoriété grâce
à vos huit enfants et bien je considère
qu'en fait vous vous êtes prisonnier de
ça pour pas grâce au 8 enfants je pense
pas si parce que famille nombreuse XXL
c'est quand même oui vous auriez pas
fait cette émission par exemple que
c'est notre c'est notre caractère à tous
les deux et c'est en fait l'alchimie de
notre couple qui a fait qu'on a duré
perdurer dans cette émission et qui et
qui fait qu'on a été du coup le
programme de cette passion là c'est un
business de ce qui nous anime nous et
nous et nous du coup monétise pas le bon
nombre d'influenceurs la promo de votre
film qui va sortir sur cette plateforme
très connue pas du tout donc voilà je
voulais même pas en parler au départ on
m'a proposé oui moi personnellement
exactement sur la même sur le sur le
même on va dire la même vous pensez quoi
vous deux là ce nouveau projet voilà
maintenant cette nouvelle étape moi je
suis toujours très très gêné pour j'ai
compris ça parce que malgré tout
vous avez le droit pour les mineurs tant
sur leur développement psychologique sur
la représentation de la sexualité encore
une fois les enfants
les enfants finiront par avoir accès à
ça ils finiront par avoir ces images là
en âge de la culpabilité ils pourront
pas vous en parler et forcément ça va ça
va forcément biaiser leur
sexualités
[Musique]
de 17 ans que s'est exprimé oui mais moi
je me permets pas votre fils il a été
absolument charmant et je l'ai trouvé
très digne et très courageeux et mon
fils et mon fils c'est lui qui a voulu
venir c'est pas c'est pas très bien
les enfants ils ont une liberté de
penser une liberté de parole très bien
mais je considère malgré tout que c'est
très dangereux pour lui c'est votre avis
mais absolument mais c'est pas là vous
pensez qu'ils sont Amandine et Alexandre
vous pensez que son ils m'ont demandé de
venir soir pour faire la promo de leur
renouveau film bah oui bien sûr c'est
pas du tout mais non
parce qu'elle voulait vous montrer
qu'elle est voilà
moi je reste sur mes positions je pense
que c'est pas un métier ce n'est pas un
métier ce que vous faites je pense que
vous avez été utilisé par une plateforme
qui surf sur votre buzz et moi pardon
mais j'en peux plus d'entendre les mots
business chef d'entreprise commerce on
dirait des patrons du CAC 40 pardon mais
vous dites où vont des contenus digitaux
à nos abonnés pardon la chauve-source
que vous vendez c'est votre cul je suis
désolé mais c'est vrai ce n'est pas un
travail
à ne pas les jours c'est de parler
pourquoi mais arrêtez de faire croire
que c'est un travail ce n'est pas un
boulot
du chat de 40
c'est un métier
c'est un métier Guillaume et oui c'est
pour alors acteur porno professionnel
c'est un métier je pense que vendre des
contenus le monde acteur porno j'ai
regardé mes vidéos elle coûte 3 euros je
trouve pardon en fait ça me fait de la
peine pour vous sur la poser des
impôts c'est le visionnage unique sur la
plateforme du du site qui diffuse le
film j'ai peur que vous ayez dans une
escalade plateforme à nous et nous
croyons qu'on a pas été payé 3 € d'une
partition ce soir à la plateforme est-ce
que vous l'avez dit ce soir vous
inquiétez pas on va faire TPMP ça va
être bien pour les vues jamais de la vie
ce n'était pas le premier motif non non
nous notre motivation pour revenir ce
soir c'est pour pouvoir nous exprimer en
fait on se fait insulter juger comme on
l'a été pendant trois soirs d'affilée on
vous a jamais insulté
ce qu'on pense vous pouvez le faire dans
le respect comme là
le film c'est pas du tout notre notre
argumentaire pour venir ce soir
absolument pas au contraire je voulais
justement mettre en avant le fait que le
gouvernement cette année allait mettre
en place justement une une comment dire
une application non pas oui une
application en tout cas une obligation
de tous les sites pornographiques en
France
justifier de
ils sont pas du tout ils sont déjà en
tout cas ils ont déjà appliqué ça depuis
longtemps
faut pas dire n'importe quoi
c'est un métier c'est un vrai travail
voilà un métier voilà c'est quelque
chose de différent néanmoins je pense et
je reste professionnel donc question moi
même ligne de ce qu'elle a dit de choix
arrêter quoi éduquer des enfants c'est
aussi un métier et je pense qu'il faut
aussi avoir une responsabilité
maintenant qu'il soit heureux qui
kiffent leur vie et qui protège leurs
enfants prenez un maximum d'argent pour
protéger vos enfants pour plus tard
s'ils ont besoin de vous vous serez là
soyez heureux qui fait voilà moi je
reste sur l'opposition je trouve que
c'est on veut tous faire des choses dans
la vie mais quand on a des enfants il
faut aussi assumer ses enfants et et
je peux dire un truc la dernière fois
Amandine elle m'a dit un truc à la fin
de l'émission elle m'a dit tout le monde
a que mon fils était génial et ben c'est
moi qui l'ai levé donc pourquoi ils
disent que j’élève mal les endroits
parce que tout le monde dit qu'il est
génial ici mais parce que une fois de
plus on n'a pas le
délinquant ça serait de ma faute on n'a
pas le retour aujourd'hui c'est facile
de dire nos enfants ne verront pas nos
vidéos ils ont 3 ans ils ont 6 ans ils
ont 6 ans on est dans le respect ou pas
donc c'est facile aujourd'hui de dire
innoveront pas les vidéos tu ne peux pas
savoir si les verrons ou pas donc moi je
pars de ce principe là je me dis que moi
aussi je voulais aussi faire des choses
mais j'ai deux enfants et j'ai préféré
assumer mes deux enfants et je suis pas
parti dans n'importe quel délire de
faire tout et n'importe quoi je pense
que se lancer c'est mon choix perso je
ne juge pas soyez heureux mais se lancer
dans le X avec 8 enfants comme ça
se lancer une fois que tu as les mêmes
enfants je pense que c'est ne pas penser
à eux je peux me tromper je suis pas
psychologique psychiatre je peux me
tromper maintenant soyez heureux faites
votre vie Amandine j'habite plein de
bonheur
[Applaudissements]
ici vous tous autour de des tables en
tant que personnalité publique vous êtes
aussi amené voilà aux critiques aux
divergences de pignons on peut aussi
très bien attaquer vos enfants parce que
tel ou le seul parents vont a priori vos
enfants sont grands et tant mieux mais
s'ils étaient petits ce serait bien
de la sexualité personne n'était moins
de rien en fait vous pensez qu'il y a
une zone bleue
il y a un âge pour tout Géraldine ange
pour tout regarder
son aval avant mais finalement
mais les images mais il les cherche pas
il faut les chercher
comme ça tu
très étriqué et en fait le dialogue
c'est pas possible parce que tu coupes
la parole moi s'il te plaît dans le cas
mais dans le respect c'est que là quand
elle dit nous on est exposé nos enfants
est-ce que tu connais les enfants de
Valérie est-ce que tu connais les
enfants
dans l'école
le savoir
Amandine Amandine Gilles on sait qui est
ta fille dans l'école
les enfants ceux qui sont les enfants
et c'est votre haine que vous répondez
moi sodomise la maman
qui a fait ça montre le moi
vous avez le droit de le faire
c'est toi l'employer ces mots-là à 20h à
20h30
qui va générer justement encore une fois
tout un montage en épingle sur les
réseaux sociaux
tu es pas bienveillante donc j'ai pas
envie de parler mais moi je suis bien
moi j'ai fait mon yoga je suis zen
je vous non
dit que tu n'allais pas parce qu'il faut
faire la part des choses tu as le droit
de pas être d'accord mais par contre tu
nous manque de respect tout le temps et
stop moi je te dis stop je n'ai pas
envie d'échanger avec toi
c'est Cyril
non je répondrai pas répondre à une
question de respect parce qu'elle est
toujours dans l'attaque en fait dans le
dénigrement c'est pas possible vous dit
juste pourquoi je trouve ça choquant
pour vos enfants et vous vous
n'êtes pas assez encore une fois
un bar je vous dis juste que tous les
enfants ont accès au porno
excuse-moi je vais réveiller
il est en train de regarder
n'importe quoi moi allez on se réveille
non mais 10 minutes
moi je comprends pas trop votre discours
par rapport voilà c'est notre kiffe
c'est on a envie de faire ça pourquoi
aller faire ça sur les réseaux et
pourquoi les chiens mais par rapport au
métier de harder quitte à faire un choix
pourquoi vous faites pas plus que ça et
pas et laisser tomber les vidéos à 3
balles à deux balles de la chaîne
justement c'est le site c'est le site
professionnel
en magnétisant nos contenus mais c'est
pas un secret mais en fait on fait ce
qu'on aime et évidemment qu'elle ne
devient avec on va pas mais on va pas
cracher dans la soupe arrêtons des types
est-ce que est-ce que on était
effectivement et on fait ce qu'on aime
donc stop est-ce que vous reconnaissez
quand même qu'il y a une escalade vers
des contenus de plus en plus explicites
Sark au début c'était des photos en
sous-vêtements après c'est des vidéos là
c'est un film alors il y a un teaser du
film qui est sorti sur spoiler mais on
vous voit effectivement
et à la fin du teaser gratuit vous
embrassez les deux coupes s'embrassent
en même temps ce qui laisse penser que
on est d'accord
c'est est-ce que vous avez pas le
sentiment d'être utilisé et est-ce que
vous avez pas peur qu'un moment vous
dites bah tiens ce site là vous proposez
une deuxième vidéo mais là pourquoi tu
utilises pour parler tous les soirs sur
C8
pas dans des vidéos pour pour
non mais c'est une question est-ce que
vous avez moi-même de ne plus avoir de
limite c'est ça la question si justement
on a toujours les mêmes limites c'est
Nous Deux personne d'autre et tu vois
d'ailleurs même on a exigé que toutes
les personnes donc l'autre couple que tu
avais à côté de nous a quitté
l'appartement et il restait plus que les
deux caméraman parce qu'on ne voulait
personne dans le en fait on voulait
personne
[Musique]
au niveau du il y avait il y avait
l'injection non il y a pas d'ingessence
c'était pas le micro euh c'est
intéressant tout ce qu'on dit
on n'est pas sur RFM ici il y a des gens
qui nous regardent mais justement
j'écoute attentivement moi je veux dire
que ils font ce qu'ils veulent toute
façon ils sont adultes c'est évident que
nous là où on s'inquiète c'est pour les
enfants c'est tout alors justement vous
faites ce que vous voulez vous êtes
majeur parce que vous voulez mais vous
vendez ce que vous voulez comme vous il
y a une question c'est les enfants c'est
ça qui est terrible mes parents le font
Clara Morgane quelques jours
et on ne l'accable
oui mais si on touche
le réseau de Madame effectivement on
nous accuse de tous les côtés non mais
je vais aller dans votre sens pour vous
aider un peu parce que je trouve qu'on
vous accable et qu'on est assez courant
avec vous si on pousse votre
raisonnement effectivement que Clara
Morgane on l'a vu de sur TF1 dans dans
l'émission de Nikos ou elle a montré le
visage de sa fille et on peut très bien
avoir retrouvé des vidéos de rien à voir
parce que clairement regarde sa fille sa
fille elle est elle a pas été connue
dans famille nombreuse
[Musique]
Amandine qu'est-ce que tu as à leur dire
ce soir parce que c'est toi qui a voulu
venir moi en fait je suis en fait
moi-même on empêche nous-mêmes nos
enfants nous les protégeons on est
toujours les mêmes parents que nous
étions il y a un an il y a 2 ans il y a
10 ans on a des enfants qui regardent
vos enfants sur vous il a pas changé
mais bien sûr que non nos enfants n'ont
absolument pas connaissance de ça
puisqu'ils ne sont pas en âge de le
savoir et le jour où ils seront en âge
de le savoir on leur expliquera encore
une fois nous on met tout en oeuvre
justement pour les prot
tout le monde en fait je vis pour ma
famille pour mon couple le reste mais je
mens tape complètement j'ai tellement
été déçu par l'être humain pendant des
années durant que clairement moi
l'essentiel il est sous le taux de ma
maison et c'est tout et je fais tout en
œuvre et je me tournef pour leur bonheur
et pour leur bien-être et je sais que je
le fais oui une question pour vous poser
une question oui si elle est objective
tu peux non la dernière fois que vous
aviez parlé à Raymonde la la psy et elle
vous avait parlé de votre jeunesse
fracassée comme quoi vous aviez une
jeune fille
vous avez quand elle vous avait parlé de
votre maman vous aviez l'air très
effectivement chamboulé en fait j'ai pas
envie de parler de ma maman c'est pas le
sujet en fait faut pas tout mélanger
entre oui ton enfant c'était si avec ta
maman c'est comme ça et du coup
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça en fait il y
a pas de de cause à effet donc c'est pas
le pourquoi du comment enfin voilà ça
s'explique cela non pas du tout ça n'a
rien à voir au contraire alors moi je me
suis pas nu dans ma vie de mère
dans ma vie de couple dans ma vie de
famille et justement j'ai trouvé ça très
large de sa part en fait dès le départ
en fait on m'a fait péter un câble on
l'a bien vu et déjà avant de rentrer en
plateau parce qu'on avait vu que cette
femme elle est elle voulait vous aider
alors juste il y a quelqu'un qui est
dans le porno qui m'écrit ce ne sont pas
des pros mais des amateurs la plateforme
se sert de leur nom pour faire des vues
mais ils ne sont mais ils ne sont mais
ils ne sont pas et ne seront jamais pro
aux yeux du milieu donc en fait c'est
que votre top chaque aura toujours une
table à Matrix
Alexandre non mais ça vous dérange ou
pas du tout mais non mais pas du tout
parce qu'en fait nous on a été nous on a
négocié notre notre cachet on a été
rémunéré pour fournir une prestation et
point et nous en fait on mise surtout
sur nos plateformes privées on se croira
à l'école Guillaume comme ça maîtresse
et en fait et non et en fait on le fait
en toute et on le fait en toute est-ce
que vous êtes heureux on est archi
heureux faites votre truc alors
c'est bien vous avez voilà vous vous
avez parlé avec eux ce soir gentiment ça
va doubler voilà c'est bien on a bien
fait de le faire bien sûr après trois
soirs d'assises
comme ça